[Music]
coming up next here on c-span an
installment in our new weekly series
book notes featuring interviews with
authors of new books this week we'll
talk with zebignu brzezinski he served
as national security advisor to
president carter and now he's the author
of the grand failure the birth and death
of communism in the 20th century
[Music]
big new brzezinski author of the grand
failure the birth and death of communism
in the 20th century why this new book
why not i write books and it seems to me
that in this particular one i'm dealing
with a truly momentous historical
development
something that is happening before our
very eyes
and yet has been touching us all
for all these decades
namely an ideology that was so dominant
in the course of this century literally
before our very eyes is disintegrating
as a system
and dying as a doctrine
that's a very important development why
is this happening well i think it's
happening largely because marxism
leninism
involved a misinterpretation of human
nature
and then by being applied
particularly in the soviet circumstances
by stalin
in such incredibly brutal
even murderous fashion
it produced not only a massive
socio-economic failure
but an incredible moral aberration
and all of that
i think has discredited it that's by not
least i think the successful performance
of the western democratic pluralistic
systems
upon not only in america but also in
western europe in japan
has created such a contrast
between
the communist world and what's outside
of it
that in the increasingly porous global
conditions with the iron curtain no
longer being so airtight
the discrepancy could no longer be
hidden
and that's causing us a massive
revulsion within the communist system
against the communist system
would you help us with history a little
bit you have a chapter in here on both
lenin and stalin start with lennon who
was he
well lenin was a russian revolutionary
an early russian marxist
a person who led the so-called majority
faction of russian marxists and the word
bolshevik is derived from the word
majority
majority faction of the russian
bolsheviks the russian marxists
who believed that marxism under russian
conditions
would have to be applied by
coercion from above remember marxism
said that
a communist system socialist system will
come out spontaneously out of the
internal contradictions of capitalism
that capitalism was not only an evil
system
but a system that would destroy itself
lenin said yes that's true but in russia
we haven't reached capitalism therefore
we have to leap history
so to speak
forward we have to leap over it
by creating socialism without capitalism
by the state
reorganizing society so he was a russian
revolution who believed
in accelerating history by using the
state
to smash society and to create in it a
communist society why did people follow
him
people followed him for a variety of
reasons inherent in the failures of the
early russian system
sarism by its last decades was corrupt
inefficient and then last but not least
very important beaten in the war
by an enemy all of which created
enormous antipathy towards terrorism
terrorism however was
followed for a very brief period of time
in russian history the only period of
time in russian history by a democratic
system which lasted from february 1917
till october
of 1917. we tend to forget that and that
is the system that lenin overthrew lenin
did not overthrow the tsar
lenin overthrew the democratic system
that replaced the tsar
and having replaced that democratic
system
then set in motion forces which many
people now in russia
and certainly i on the outside of it
believe
led directly to stalinism
now today and i talk about that in my
book
the dismantling of stanninism in russia
has gone very far and stalin is
discredited
but the dismantling is done in the name
of leninism gorbachev says i'm returning
to true leninism
the problem with that is
and that problem is perceived by many
people in russia itself that it was
lenin
who made stalin possible
it was lenin who set in motion forces
that created stalinism because it was
lenin who emphasized two very basic
things
one
the party is all-knowing
and the party has the right to all power
monopoly of power and one leading party
and secondly he said terror
can be used against our opponents
and the combination of party monopoly
and terrorism
created very fertile soil
for staminism how long was london in
power
well london was in power until he died
in 1923.
and where was joseph stalin during the
time that he that lenin was in power he
was one of his associates
at that time not thought to be the
preeminent one there were other people
around
lenin who people thought would succeed
him people like trotsky for example who
was
also a revolutionary bolshevik who
believed however that the revolution
should immediately expand outside
whereas stan and said no let's
consolidate the revolution inside let's
build it in russia socialism in one
country
there were other people who were then
more preeminent than stan and people
like zinoviev
also a leading of the international
communist movement
and these are the people that by very
skillful maneuvering stalin
isolated after london's death
gradually denigrated
and eventually literally quite literally
murders
how much of
this book
and the previous books you've written
are a product of the fact that you were
born and raised in poland how much of
that experience impacts the way you
think today
well you know that would make sense if
you said that and if my view was
fundamentally different from the views
of most americans
now when i discuss foreign policy issues
and i've been invite involved in some
public policy matters have served in the
government
i have found that my views on the soviet
union are shared probably by 70
americans now 70 of most americans were
not born in poland yeah so there goes
the argument let me let me ask a
different way
what was it like how long did you live
in poland only three years of my life so
you moved over here in what year i was i
moved over here the age of 10. i lived
in poland from the age of seven to the
age of ten
which is long enough to have some
memories
although it's not long enough to be
decisively formative
when was the last time you were in
poland last year
and when you go back what impact does it
have on you
what do you see now today
well i see a society with which
linguistically historically i obviously
have connections
and for which i have the deepest of
affection
but also a society which incidentally
has lived under communist system now for
40 years
and which has been
close to destroyed
by that system
and the infrastructure society is
in a state of disintegration
the ecological crisis in poland is worse
than in any country in the world
literally because of the totally
ruthless
indiscriminate
communist policies regarding the
industrialization of the country
i see a country which is deeply
religious
very spiritual
but also
a country in which the political culture
has been badly damaged
by 40 years of
rule by single and a relatively corrupt
party because not forget communism in
poland is very different from communism
in the soviet union
in that in the soviet union whatever you
may say about it it is still indigenous
it came out of an internal revolution
so that some social elements supported
that revolution and in fact prevailed
in poland as in hungary east german in
czechoslovakia romania bulgaria
communism was really
entirely an external imposition
it was brought in from the outside by
the soviet army this is incidentally why
in my book
i differentiate between the changes that
are taking place and which cumulative we
are spelling the end of communism
between what is more specifically
happening in eastern europe or in the
soviet union or in china
because the crisis of communism
manifests itself in different ways in
these three major sectors of the
communist world in eastern europe is
what i call organic rejection
the social systems are simply
repudiating rejecting
is externally imposed formation
let's go back to uh karl marx
who was he when did he write
and why did people follow him well he
was a german jewish scholar self-taught
who actually spent most of his time
living in england and wrote in england
and he wrote about the rise of the
capital system
and he provided a comprehensive
interpretation of history
in the context of which he postulated
the proposition
that capitalism is not only socially
immoral
because of the oppression and
exploitation that it breeds
and much of that incidentally was true
in terms of early 19th century
capitalism
but he also argued that the capitalist
system had internal contradictions
which would ultimately give rise to a
revolutionary working class the
proletariat which would overthrow the
capital system and produce a much more
morally just
and effective socialist system
and that
that socialism would then be a stage
on the road to an eventual communist
system
and that would be in a in a sense if you
will the end of history because
communism would be in effect a utopia a
state of well-being of total social
justice
complete self-fulfillment
what's the difference between communism
and socialism
well in the marxist theory the
difference between socialism and
communism is
that socialism is the first phase after
capitalism when you socialize the
previously owned private
industries and properties and try to
create more equitable social
relationships but you haven't reached
yet the stage of full communism in which
everyone contributes according to his
ability but everyone gets
according to his need and there is a
state of total social justice it's the
final fulfillment of you will of the
socialist ideal a state of genuine
equality
total self satisfaction
what do you think karl marx would say if
he came back today and looked at what's
happened to his theory
well if he looked at what happened to
his theory in the soviet context i think
he'd be appalled by it
for one thing presumably he would be
aware of the fact that for some 25 years
quote unquote socialism was being built
by the
worst
murderer in history
i try in my book to provide some sort of
statistical analysis joseph of joseph
stalin's killings quite literally you
say by the way before we leave that that
that the
the
number that we most often reach 20
million you say it could be as many as
40 million people right that's right
how did he kill them
in a variety of ways quite a few of them
by shooting but on a massive massive
scale you know we're now discovering
graves
next to every large soviet city
graves with thousands of people
for example near minsk
a city before the war of sort of half a
million people
they have discovered mass graves which
according to the calculations of those
who dug them up
numbered probably as many as 101
000 people shot in the course of four
years
101
000 people
now the soviet government has
investigated this and the soviet secret
police which is the inheritor of the
nkvd which carried out these executions
has issued a statement saying that's a
vastly exaggerated figure the number was
only 30 000.
now since then that is a place near
means called kuropati
since then they have discovered mass
graves near kiev
in some cemeteries in moscow
in the al-taikrai
and searches are now going on in every
major city
now stan literally shot
thousands hundreds of thousands probably
several million people
then there were people who died during
mass deportations carried out under
extraordinary inhuman conditions
then there were mass executions in the
camps
we now know from documentary evidence
that periodically among the many
prisoners held in camps and the number
was in the tens of millions tens of
millions in camps periodically an order
would arrive saying
10 percent are to be liquidated
just like that
or in local secret police
offices sometimes an order would arrive
saying it is estimated that in your
region
there are 15
enemies of the people
and that was clearly an order to the
local secret police
to ferret out 15 of the people
because they didn't they would be guilty
of the religion of duty and the same
thing would happen to them
now someone listening to us talk might
say this is just crazy this guy's
mouthing on the soviet propaganda
the tragedy
of the circumstances is that people
don't believe such things
because we cannot imagine them
unless they are confirmed by the
perpetrators themselves
and now we are getting that confirmation
from the perpetrators themselves
because we're getting access to the
archives
and the figures that i have given in my
book
which i then try to total for the
communist world as a whole
are probably very thin conservative
i say that conservatively speaking
the communist experiment from 1917 to
the present subsequently expanded to
china and to eastern europe
conservatively speaking
probably passed at a minimum of 50
million lives
and that's very conservative
because in fact it's probably more we
don't know exactly what the costs were
in china
and they're quite substantial
i interrupted you you were talking about
marx and what he would feel like if he
saw it was going in the soviet union and
you mentioned joseph stalin well first
of all he'd be appalled by the past but
secondly in terms of the present i think
he would be appalled by the inequality
we have public opinion polls from the
soviet union which showed that one of
the things which outrages the soviet
public the most
is the social inequality
socialism in the soviet union is
socialism for one class
for the ruling class
that is to say if you're a member of the
social elite you have access to special
hospitals
your children go to special schools
your special resorts
your special shops you go to
your special clinics
everything for the elite is special for
the masses conditions are extremely bad
and have been getting worse so i would
imagine that with a paul marx
but what might even upon marx more is
not what he would see in the soviet
union it's what he would see in the west
namely that capitalism
instead of being torn asunder by its
contradictions
and becoming increasingly unjust
in fact has been able both to adapt
to innovate
not to disintegrate for economic and
social reasons and also to create a
greater measure of social justice by
becoming more socially responsive
so i think he would be appalled by what
happened to his doctrine
but also surprised
by what happened to his predictions
regarding capitalism itself
we're talking with dr zbignan brzezinski
he has a new book out that you just saw
on your screen called the grand failure
dr brzezinski is a professor at columbia
university in new york city and also is
associated here in washington with the
as a counselor for the center for
strategic and international studies a
couple little things on this book
dedicated to mrs emily bennis that's my
mother-in-law my daughter my wife
is
banished banished where
a czech political family
another very small little item here and
our camera will pick it up here is a
picture of you in the back and i noticed
that on the
credits it's mushka that's my wife
yes does she uh does she often do this
kind of work well no only if i insist on
it actually she's a very well-known and
recognized sculptor who's doing very
well
in her field photography is not her
field but i needed a picture i didn't
want to go to a professional camera
store and she did that picture this book
is published by scribners do they always
publish your books no i have been moving
from publisher publisher but i've been
very happy with the relationship with
scriveners what happens when you write a
book like this are you now in the stage
where you
make trips around the country to promote
the board well up to a point
unfortunately i don't have the time to
travel around too much i think my
interview with you is one of the few
things i can do and i have given some
time to the promotion this book but i
cannot travel around the country simply
too busy with other things what are you
doing now well you've mentioned two of
them and those are major activities i'm
a professor at colombia
where i teach a seminar in a course
and i commute to new york from
washington where i live in washington
i'm located at the center for strategic
international studies where i have my
office
where i do my writing where i do my
thinking where i interact with the
activities of the center
beyond that i serve on some presidential
boards
in the area of strategy and intelligence
i'm a consultant to the government
effect
and i'm also involved in some private
consulting
on international affairs some speaking
of international affairs to business
groups
and last but not least i'm an honorary
chairman
of a prompt reaction relief organization
that responds whenever there's a crisis
very quickly it's called the americares
foundation
and our claim to fame so to speak is
that we are in
with a very quick response if there's a
calamity later on the large
organizations come in on a bigger volume
scale
but we're in there very quickly can you
give me an example of something that
you've been involved in well jeb bush
when he went to uravan went with
americares and maracas was in their
first
two or three days after it happened
when there was a calamity in nicaragua
and colombia we did that
when chernobyl struck we were in poland
with powdered milk for children
immediately and things of that sort
we've done this on a large scale
worldwide
go back to your own past um your father
was a diplomat
american diplomat no polish department
you said you left paul on it when you
were 10 years old where did you go to
canada
how long did you live in canada i lived
in canada from 1938 to 1950 i went to
school in canada i went to an english
prep school
and it was real english prep school done
canada the headmaster used to refer to
canada's bma but you don't know what
that stands for i'm sure my viewers
don't know either it stands for british
north america
he used to tell us the sun never sets on
the british empire and then i went to
mcgill and from mcgill i went to harvard
and
one thing led to another and here i am
why did you pick harvard
i was told it's not a bad school
after harvard where'd you go
after harvard well i after i got my
degree at harvard i taught at harvard
i taught at harvard until 1960 then in
1960 i went to columbia university
and have been a professor
there since then but periodically i have
been involved public affairs so for
example in the mid 60s
i was on the policy planning council of
the department of state
in 1960 i was marginally involved in the
kennedy
campaign for president foreign policy
brain trust
in 1968
i directed the foreign policy task
forces for vice president humphrey when
he was running for the presidency
in 1972
i became director of the trilateral
commission an american japanese west
european public organization
in 1976
i directed the foreign policy task
forces for
jimmy carter then i became his national
security adviser for four years
then i went back to private life
although in 1988
i was co-chairman
with brent scalcroft and henry kissinger
of the foreign policy task force
for vice president bush
why did you make the switch politically
i can answer one word
dukakis
because of his views yes i just felt
that his use in foreign policy straight
so far
from the traditional bipartisan
consensus on foreign policy and
certainly on substance in terms of
specific issues quite far from jimmy
carter's foreign policy that i could not
support it
let me ask you about your experience uh
as a national security advisor for jimmy
carter
what did that do to the way you now look
at government did it change at all
after your experience oh yes there's no
doubt that an experience of that sort
affects your perception although as i
have already indicated this was not my
first service in government but it
certainly was at a different level
well one thing you learn immediately is
the enormous limitations on presidential
power
and that's easy to say and i suppose
intellectually we're all aware of it
but in fact once you're in there
you begin to realize the extraordinary
variety of pools and pressures that the
president is under
and difficulty of articulating and
formulating and then implementing a
foreign policy
another thing you learn is that once you
make a decision on the presidential
level
let's say the national security advisor
on behalf of the president issues an
instruction
the secretary of state and the secretary
of defense the president wants this or
that done
and they say yes we'll do it
but if it turns out the bureaucracy
doesn't like it
while doing it they'll alter it
so that in addition to making policy
you really have to be continuously
involved in
verifying the implementation of policy
and making certain that things don't get
skewed in some fashion either
accidentally or more often than not
deliberately
because the bureaucracy didn't want it
in the first place
so that
task of government is essentially a
continuous incremental
decision-making
and continuous
uphill struggle
to make sure that your will is
implemented
overcoming an enormous amount of
obstacles trying to build consensus
beyond not only the government but first
of all
with the congress
and then beyond the government including
the congress with the mass media who are
now such an important element
in the shaping of public attitudes
it's a staggering uh
staggering task and one gets
a sense of the
probably incomprehensible handicaps
under which the top policy makers
operate which people on the outside
don't quite realize
kind of job you think the mass media
does in this town as it relates to
foreign policy
mixed mixed i can't say frankly that
it's top notch
i don't think it's terrible i think
there are elements of both there are
some people i don't want to mention
names obviously
who write very perceptive thoughtful
either analyses or focus their stories
on
significant truths
but there is also an enormous number of
human mass media who are first of all
devoid of any ideas of their own who
just follow the pack
who are essentially
digging for sensations
and who because of the experience of the
seventies more often than not
automatically assume that anyone who is
in the government is either a crook or
an enemy
who has to be exposed and attacked
and who are not prepared to believe that
most people in the government are
generally dedicated patriotic people who
in many cases are honestly making a
major sacrifice doing what they're doing
there is a kind of i think in some cases
mindless antipathy
within the mass media
which occasionally is even stimulated by
either an abrasive or overly arrogant
personality of a decision maker
but these personal phobias tend to i
think color a great deal of the
reporting after administration has been
in office for a little while and certain
lines of
either attraction or antagonism have
surfaced
you mentioned something earlier that
you've done that comes up right in the
spot that you're sitting many times by
our callers across the country
and that is a suspicion that there is a
conspiracy to put
through the trilateral commission in the
council on foreign relations
you ran the trilateral commission for
how long about three years i think
something like that three years not only
did i run it i helped to found it and
organize it with david rockefeller so if
any of our viewers are conspiracy minded
here is one of the conspirators
let's talk about it for just a moment
how big is it how many people physically
belong the trilateral commission when we
first started it and let me repeat again
so the viewers will know we're talking
about it's an american north american
western european japanese organization
to promote closer contacts between these
three regions of the world and the
commission's composed of private
citizens not government officials
who are leaders in the different
sectors of society so when we first
started we sought a commission of about
60 people
and initially when i was first helping
to organize it we had a hard time
recruiting those 60 people because it
was a brand new idea which the two of us
had thought of
in rockefeller 9.
now we have 360 people
with an enormous waiting list
it's been an eminently successful
operation obviously filling a major need
for
a community of dialogue and cooperation
between these three regions we're
incidentally the ones who proposed
originally
the holding of the annual summit meeting
of the industrial democracy that was an
idea that originated with us in the
trilateral community seven nation
economic summit yeah
how do you become a member
you become a member by invitation issued
by the respective executive committees
of the commission the commission has 360
members a smaller executive committee
the executive committee has its own
regional sort of identity so if you want
to be a member of the american one the
north american executive committee has
to invite you i say north american
because this is both a canadian and a
u.s
activity
is there any reason for the audience to
think
that this is a bad organization that
conspires to
and i want to make sure i represent what
they say is that this this group
really guides the foreign policy of this
country well you know i can i can tell
you even better what this group
represents what people think this group
represents people who are
conspiratorially minded because i
encounter that all the time
when i speak around the country and
the kooks that you know pop up with this
theory come either from the extreme
loony left wing or the looney right-wing
perspective if it's a looney
right-winger he'll stand up and say
you're a conspiracy of people who want
to impose one world government
and the privacy of our sovereignty
and if it's an extremely
loony left winger he'll stand up and say
you're a conspiracy
of rich capitalists who want to control
the world for the sake of global profits
and that crazy outfit la
started with the left and swung to the
right for example over the last 15 years
um
but the answer is look the commission
operates openly there's nothing secret
about it
it is
a group of influential people we don't
hide that in the country we deliberately
want influential people
from the three regions
who try to
deal with the problems that the three
regions encounter by discussion by
promotion of studies by advocacy
we have advocated over the years debt
relief for the poor countries of the
world
we have advocated a variety of eight
programs for the third world
we have advocated closer cooperation and
science between our industrial
democracies we are by and large in favor
of a free trade
arrangement we are against
protectionism areas
we have currently a major study going on
in east-west relations
produced by authors from the three
regions uh i think we perform a useful
educational function and any viewer who
is watching me wants to explore the
so-called conspiracy even more all he
has to do is to write to the office of
the commission and we'll give him
whatever papers she wants there's
nothing secret about it let's go back to
this book
the grand failure
the birth and death of communism in the
20th century
we've talked a little bit about stalin
and lenin and marx
but we haven't touched on mr gorbachev
right what do you think of it
well i think one has to differentiate
between mr gorbachev the person the
human being
and
the likely fate of the policies that
he's promoting
he certainly is a very intelligent an
attractive person i have had the
opportunity of meeting him not for long
but i did and he makes a very good
impression certainly better than any of
his predecessors
and that clearly explains also why he's
so attractive because he stands in such
contrast to those who preceded him
his policies
which are based on two russian words
that have come to be well known
glasnost and pierre stroika glasnost
meaning avertness purestoica meaning
restructuring
are designed to promote a reform of the
system that he himself recognizes has
become stagnant and uncreated
my own judgment regarding his policies
which i try to express in the book
is that first of all there has been much
more glassness in the soviet union than
perestroika meaning they talk much more
and they ventilate issues much more
openly than they ever have
but reforming the system has proven to
be very difficult
my own expectation is that he will not
succeed
in creating
a spontaneously
self-energizing increasingly pluralistic
or generally open soviet union
that there are too many inbuilt
contradictions
legacies of the past within the soviet
system to make that kind of success for
his policies possible and that therefore
his major historical significance will
be
that he will have dismantled stalinism
probably not
dismantled leninism
which means this one-party rule legacy
a kind of a doctrinal doctrinal
orthodoxy
and that he will
have initiated a protracted systemic
crisis in the soviet union which will
last for many years
as all of these internal contradictions
and legacies of the past work themselves
out
should we trade and provide
money and technology for them
well i think there's a difference
between those two aspects trade or
providing money and technology trade i
don't have any objections to there's
something we can buy from them and
there's something we don't want to buy
from us of course why not
should we
quote unquote aid
no on that i would be hesitant because
after all we don't know how long
gorbachev is going to last
we don't know who will succeed him
we do know that the soviet military
power is still enormous but not very
much has been done to reduce that
and hence at this stage no
commitments that are truly irreversible
towards either a free market economic
system
or an open pluralistic political system
have been made
and until they're made and they're truly
irrevocable
we could be
in fact aiding his successor who could
turn out to be again assertive hostile
or we may be simply throwing
money away
because until there is
very significant change i doubt very
much that the economy will become so
productive as to make western investment
in the soviet union truly productive
now we invested a lot of money i say we
meaning the west in eastern europe in
the soviet union in the 70s
in eastern europe alone it was in the
tens of billions of dollars
and all of that was wasted
all of that was wasted because the
systems weren't reformed and they simply
wasted the money
in the back of your book talking about
money and you had we won't be able to
show a lot of this that's why people
want to see more than gotten by your
book but you can see if we can get a
close-up of this james um i believe uh
this particular
table here shows down here and we're
gonna have to get real close on it if we
can so that we can see the difference
between
the dark lines belong to the united
states
second line i believe there belongs to
the soviet union the third line of japan
and this is a gross national product
uh
what are there 280 million people in the
soviet union that's right 100 million
people in japan and 250 million people
in the united states why are we so far
ahead and why is the soviet union so far
behind well i think it's inherent what
we were talking about
not only are we ahead of the soviet
union but now the japanese are ahead of
the soviet union and that is a dramatic
change you know only 25 years ago
khrushchev was predicting and sometimes
he was even very crude about it that the
soviet union would surpass the united
states in total production and then in
per capita production and their
population being larger than us that's
an even greater accomplishment
and he was absolutely convinced that by
the 1970s the soviet union would be the
number one economic power in the world
instead as this table shows
they have fallen further behind us
and now they're behind the japanese
and of course in western europe unites
they'll be ahead of the soviet union and
it's even conceivable though not certain
that china will surpass the soviet union
elsewhere in the book i have tables
which generally compare
the performance of comparable communist
and non-communist countries
poland and spain here's one let me show
you here's one trade and competitive
world markets
uh it is that one he just said is poland
and spain yeah we'll the audience will
be able to see it just i know they start
off originally very very similar almost
the same level and then the gap
widens and widens and widens in favor of
spain spain is the dark line spain is a
dark line why is that what what is it at
the core that makes these two countries
so different well i think the fact that
in spain they did retain
a market economy decentralized oriented
towards trade both externally and
internally whereas in poland they impose
a state controlled heavy industrial
monopoly on the economy and gradually
suffocated it
in effect
what do you think of capitalism let me
ask you a little different what's wrong
with capitalism
well capitalism is not a perfect system
but i think
one has to bear in mind first of all
that we in the west don't think of
social systems as utopias
the way marxists conceived of communism
as a utopia as a perfection
we realize the imperfection of our
institutions and arrangements though we
strive gradually if we can to improve
them
capitalism has many things wrong with it
if it's unchecked it can be very various
it can be very insensitive to human
values
it can be cruel to the weak
it in a sense in its purest sense
enshrines darwinism to survival of the
fittest but that's why over the years we
have tried to combine capitalism
with increasing measures of social
responsibility
social sensitivity
attempts to
indirectly
recreate even opportunities for every
generation
but without stifling
individual initiative and self-interest
which are very deeply felt instincts
that if properly channeled
can make a society creative and wealthy
and if suppressed produce the kind of
stagnation which i call the grand
failure
how do you write books
what's your what's your pattern
well
that's i'm using actually this is not my
first book i've written a number of
books before
and until this one i used to write by
hand
i would outline it first of all very
systematically i always have a concept
of a book in my mind and in fact
that kind of
germinates within me gradually very
often for example on sundays i sit in
church
ideas will begin to form in my mind and
my mind sort of operates on its own and
then i begin to feel after some months
that there's something i want to say and
i start outlining it and i never start
writing a book until i have a full
outline ready and then until this book i
used to write it by hand then revise it
and then dictate it into a dictating
machine have it transcribed and then
edit it and so forth
this one i received out of the blue from
the apple
corporation
a macintosh computer and a printer as a
gift and from a chief from a senior
executive there
who thought
that i might be interested in because i
once visited their headquarters
i had never thought of buying a computer
in a word processor
and i started playing around with it
and i started enjoying it
and then at that particular moment i had
some ideas along these lines but i
really wasn't thinking writing a book
but since i had this damn
contraption in front of me that i
enjoyed playing with i said well i'm
going to start outlining on this thing
and see how it works and i started
outlining it
on the word processor on the screen
and then printed it out and i said well
gee this looks like a little outline why
don't i start flashing it out a little
bit and lo and behold just during the
summer month i wrote the first chapter
which is called the grand failure which
gives the title of the book
and then i said to myself well
obviously i have a book here so i'll
continue writing it and
that's how it came into being i noticed
that in the author's notes it says big
new brzezinski northeast harbor maine
august 31 1988. did you write this in
maine that's exactly right that's where
i spend my summer holidays at least
august nothing past summer how long does
it take you to write a book like this
well this one took me about
well from the writing process took me
about 15 months
or so maybe a little less than that the
actual the actual writing process i
started writing it probably
a year earlier maybe in july june
somewhere around there
you have to worry about the fact that
once it's written it takes some months
to get it into print yeah and that
things can change
yes but
for example in this particular book i
say in the preface that this book was
completed in august of 88 and there will
be events taking place
which will outpace the book but that i
hope the reader will find that the book
gives them a framework for understanding
what is happening that is helpful to him
and i really do believe quite seriously
although obviously i'm biased since it's
my book but i believe if someone reads
this book and then reads the newspapers
about let's say national riots and the
soviet union
or the new maritime economic zones in
china
or the discussions in hungary in poland
about pluralism
and changes of the existing political
system that this book will give them a
framework
for understanding the significance of
these developments and a framework which
makes them alert to the fact
that we're living really through
momentous historical change
that this pertains to the fact that an
ideology which shaped much of the
century
which was the dominant force that
influenced our lives for better for
worse
before our very eyes is disintegrating
and dying now this is a very major
historical development that we are
entering the post-communist era
an era in which communism is no longer
going to be a major philosophical
political force in world affairs this is
a threshold
era in that sense and i hope that's what
the reader will get out of it and then
when he reads a newspaper watches
television about yerevan and the riots
in armenia or about the lithuanians
demanding freedom etc he'll have a
framework in which he can understand
these events you asked me earlier about
american news reporting
it's very good when it comes to
reporting events
it's not so good
when it comes to interpreting them
seeing them as part of larger historical
trends
and i think my book perhaps
helps the reader
to understand what is actually happening
and not just to what is in the book
what else happens when you write a book
who will for sure read a book like this
let's go to the present united states
the president of the united states has
already been reading it i would have a
note from him
and
we had suffered not long ago and we
talked about it
so when you sat down to write it did you
think that that would eventually happen
i mean is that always going in your mind
are you looking at it in your own mind's
eye an audience out there of power
well
yeah but not necessarily of the
president although
in this particular case
i was aware of the fact the president
and i know each other and that i would
certainly send him a copy i didn't know
whether he would read it or not
and but that's happened i wrote another
book
prior to this one called game plan which
was more of a strategic book
which dealt with weapons and geopolitics
and i sent a copy of it to reagan on i
remember thursday morning thursday
afternoon he phoned me up
and told me i've just read the following
20 pages in it and told me what pages he
read so i immediately went to the book
and looked up what he had read and was a
section on the sdi the strategic defense
initiative
but when i write a book like this i
really write it for a larger audience i
would hope that people who
realize that our lives and the lives of
our children are influenced by what
happens in the world
and have some interest there for what is
happening in the world
either because they read
major newspapers or they read magazines
like foreign affairs or they watch
the tv shows that pertain to world
affairs
will find the book helpful
in understanding and the real important
word here is understanding what is
happening in world affairs it isn't what
the facts what facts they get out of
this book because i can find those facts
elsewhere probably
it's not that the book contains
sensational new facts it's the
interpretation the understanding that
they gain
so that when they think about the world
they'll have a new insight into what is
happening in the world for example a
very simple one among others communism
is dying
a very major change is taking place what
is its significance what does it portend
for eastern europe for china for the
soviet union for world affairs
what does it
pretend for us
i think it pretends for us that the
soviet challenge henceforth would be
only military
is the soviet military any good yes it's
pretty good it's not
as good as they have thought and all
military discovers shortcomings where it
gets involved in combat after prolonged
period of peace so we discovered that in
afghanistan but there's no doubt that
soviet equipment is good that's the one
area of soviet industry where they
produce good stuff why are they able to
produce good military equipment and
nothing else
because they have a motivation
whereas nowhere else do they have a
motivation they don't have a consumer
market they don't have competition
but in this area they do have
competition
and they concentrate their resources
any reaction from the president after he
read the book what did he tell you about
well he told me he was reading it and
you know that's good enough for me and
because i saw him couple days afterwards
no i have not talked to him since when
you see a president and you're no longer
in government at the moment
what goes on in your own mind about what
kind of things you want him
to know
during a meeting like that well
it's probably the same thing that i
always had in my mind when i dealt with
the president i was actually working for
namely
i've always been very conscious of the
fact that the president is saturated
with information
torn as we talked earlier by conflicting
pools
and that therefore i render him no
service
by coming in with another two-bit idea
or another bit of some fact
factology as i call it
what the president needs very much and
very rarely gets
is some
significant generalization
or some integrative proposal that
enables him
to
move forward if you will
strategically yeah so when i speak to a
president unless i'm engaging in social
chit chat
i try to
give him if i can
some sort of broad formulation that
helps him
grasp
various
parts of a picture
and see it in a larger frame
either as an initiative that you have to
undertake or as an insight that you got
to have
because i think that is where presidents
are
worst served by the system and even by
their advisors
are there a couple of camps that are
operating now in this town when it comes
to foreign policy
no not yet not yet
i think for one thing the administration
has
a not fully organized itself
in foreign affairs the only shop that's
really in good shape as of our
conversation today
is brent scowcroft's national security
council the state department hasn't yet
been put together and of course the
unfortunate delays connected with the
town nomination
have prevented the defense department
from being put together
so that the president's for in the
president's national security team
not at the very top but at the echelons
below it
has not been fully put together
now until that has happened and until
they will have had time to meet and
discuss some foreign policy issues will
not have these camps the camps will
surface once there are divisions and
real also conflicts of personality
that's too early for that
this may not be possible but what would
be the two different camps on an issue
like the soviet union right now
well i think the two camps would be very
simply put those who would say let's be
prudent let's wait let's not do much
and those who would say
gorbachev needs our help let's rush in
give him help those are very extreme and
broad over simplification where are you
i would lean towards the first
what about china
well on china i don't think there's too
much division i think everybody
recognizes that the american chinese
relationship has evolved very well
first president nixon
broke through and established a contact
then president carter broke through and
normalized relations
since then the political the economic
the military relationship has grown well
and president bush has a lot of feeding
and sensitivity for china he understands
china well
he is in my judgment
the first president we have had
for whom our relationship with the
pacific
is just spontaneously naturally felt to
be as important as our relationship with
the atlantic japan
well the same thing goes for japan he
has that feeling and that grasp and
there's no other relationship with japan
on balance is a good one we have a
number of conflictual issues with the
japanese
but the white house was very right in
saying when bush was leaving for japan
that this today is for us
the single most important bilateral
relationship we have with any country in
the world
and it is true would be the two camps on
japan well the two camps in japan would
be those who would say let's throw the
book at them
let's force them to back down force them
maybe also to harm more and those who
would say
those are important issues but let's put
them in a framework of closer
cooperation so that we become bound more
together and in that context we can work
out these conflictual issues where are
you on the second
central america nicaragua
well
i don't know again whether camps exists
but once they will form it'll probably
be on the question of how how hard we
press
in sustaining the contras
in dealing with panama
and
although you know you can't put these
things together
here i think there's a general problem
that we don't at this stage have policy
i don't think they're camps yet
we don't have a policy what would you do
if you were in the position of making a
decision on what to do with the contra
aid
well
i would certainly
feel that we have a moral obligation
towards the contras we have undertaken
to armed and to send them the battle
then we undercut him i don't think great
power can act like that towards people
we can't yank him around on a yo-yo so i
think the first obligation we have is to
determine what is our long-term strategy
obtain congressional support for it and
then sustain it
but not try to do it from
one battle with congress to another
battle of congress because then we'll
lose some we'll win some but the result
is going to be a very incoherent policy
and i don't think we have sat down and
really decided what our strategy is
once we do i think the thing to do would
be to
truly sit down with chairman pal
chairman nunn
the minority leaders and see if we can
fashion a foreign policy we can sustain
for a few years
this yanking around that we have been
subject to is terribly destructive for
everybody
we've got six or seven minutes left i
want to ask you about students do you
teach kids anymore yeah when i teach
colombia and their kids and some of them
are graduate students some of them are
undergraduates
what do you think of today's student
they're very good very serious very
motivated
there's some interesting changes in them
when i taught earlier at harvard and
columbia more often than not my best
students were jewish kids jewish
americans most often
and today some of my best students are
oriental americans
that's quite an interesting change
korean americans japanese americans
chinese americans
and that i think probably foreshadows
some interesting cultural changes in
american society
but kids that i deal with are very
serious very motivated interested in
policy i don't teach abstract political
science with all the
what i call
theoretical conceptual baloney
i try to teach kids to deal with
politics in a real sense
i have a very large class for example
one of the largest classes in columbia
250 students which i teach as if i was
running a national security council
meeting and i alternatively briefed the
president in it
then i argue
as if i was in the secretary of state
then i give the defense secretary's
point of view then i inject some
warnings from the cia then the domestic
advisors of the president tell the
president of the domestic dilemmas
then i again as national security
adviser outlined the options for the
president three or four options
that he has to pick and give the pros
and cons and i try to balance the
advantages and the disadvantages then i
ask the class to vote on the options and
to get them engaged in which ones they
prefer and then bang i become the
president announce my choice and dismiss
the class the students love it
and then i teach a seminar in which for
example the last one i taught it as if
we were a bunch of advisors to the
president-elect
giving him advice on the foreign policy
he should pursue the next four years
students had to prepare papers on that
but the one who's presenting it
would always represent the paper on the
subject regarding which he also hoped to
become the apunti
so he would want to be the secretary of
state or the fans or maybe an assistant
secretary for europe
and then the other members of the
president's team all of whom share the
desire that i'm elected
would critique him
in such a manner as to expose the
weaknesses and in the hope that one of
them
would replace that person as the nominee
for that job
and i taught the students first of all
that you have to demonstrate that you
know the subject better but then
secondly don't be too aggressive
if you're overly aggressive you're not a
team player you won't get that [ __ ]
either
so i try to teach them what real
politics is about and not a lot of
theoretical
paradigms and concepts which prepare you
in life to do on the one thing
to teach other people the same concepts
and patterns so that they in turn can
teach them other people i usually begin
my class by telling my students look in
recent history in america there have
only been two people who study political
science have played a major role in
washington kissinger 9.
the rest have been played by lawyers and
economists historians
that's because political science has
been taught in a very sterile fashion
which doesn't prepare you
for dealing with the life of real
politics
students seem to like those lessons
what's what are the what's the politics
of a student today compared to what they
may have been 20 years ago very
conservative
much more conservative
i organize my students sometimes in
teams
you know and i deliberately try to
structure them sort of soft line
hardline etc and then have clashes and
lately i've had many more volunteers for
the hard
approach over the south approach
what's causing that well cultural change
in the country the country's more
conservative you see that in the
election of reagan
and what's causing that
well that was of course much more
complicated i suppose vietnam has a lot
to do with it
a general sense of drift that developed
in the course of the 70s
requests for some deeper verities
but i think the picture culture is very
mixed because we are simultaneously
maybe a more conservative society
but we're also a more hedonistic society
with focus on self-gratification
self-fulfillment
those are troubling signs
where is that going to lead us
well as i said these are troubling signs
because that could mean
cultural dissolution
loss of
the kind of values that make a society
great competitive assertive
certain degree of self-righteousness
and commitment
are necessary ingredient ingredients
of social cohesion and social dynamism
but if those troubling signs came to
life would that or or they followed to a
maturity would that mean that capitalism
then was its own victim
well it could but that i doubt because
you know the one area where capitalism
is really successful is in gratifying
material wants
and the desire for
the satisfaction of material ones is
still a very major source
of social motivation
so i don't think it's going to be a
crisis of capitalism as such because of
these cultural difficulties it could be
simply a crisis of
social commitment social virility
we could become a decadent society
that's not the crisis of capitalism it's
a crisis however our culture and if we
become a decadent society then we could
be vulnerable
this is the book it's called the grand
failure and our special guest is right
there on the covers big new brzezinski
who's former national security adviser
to president jimmy carter is currently a
counselor with the center for strategic
and international studies and also a
professor at columbia university in new
york
thank you very much for joining us this
is big new brzezinski i enjoy it thank
you
[Music]
this interview with sebignor brzezinski
will re-air monday morning at about 6 20
a.m eastern time 3 20 pacific
and join us next week on book notes for
an interview with bruce odes the author
of from the president richard nixon's
secret files that's coming up next
sunday at 8pm eastern time
stay with us now as capital agenda looks
at what's ahead on capitol hill that's
coming up next
[Music]
up next capital agenda c-span's weekly
look at hearings legislation and forms
scheduled